tanto la mitosis como la meiosis son
formas de división celular que generan
células hijas que contienen la
información genética de la célula madre
inciso a describe dos eventos que sean
comunes tanto en la mitosis como en la
meiosis que aseguren que las células
hijas resultantes heredan el número
apropiado de cromosomas muy bien
entonces cuáles son dos puntos en común
entre las dos bueno puedo pensar en
varios se podría comenzar diciendo que
el adn se replica antes de entrar en
cualquiera de los dos procesos
adn se réplica
antes de que comience
cualquiera
de los dos procesos y podríamos decir
que
la cromatina se condensa
formando cromosomas podrías decir que
los cromosomas se alinean cerca del
centro de la célula unidos a fibras o
podríamos hablar de las citocinas y la
división de las células
cito síntesis
qué consiste
en la separación
del citoplasma
para crear
a las células
hijas en general la meiosis 2 tiene una
gran cantidad de eventos análogos con la
mitosis podríamos seguir licitando más y
más pero solo nos piden que escribamos
dos eventos y ya tenemos tres así que lo
voy a dejar así por ahora en general
antes de tomar el examen ap es bueno que
conozcas la mitosis y la meiosis a
detalle porque es posible que veas este
tipo de preguntas en la sección de
respuestas libres o también es probable
que aparezcan en la sección de preguntas
de opción múltiple pero creo que esto es
suficiente para el inciso a hemos
descrito al menos dos eventos que son
comunes tanto a la mitosis como la
meiosis si tienes tiempo extra puedes
tratar de enumerar más ahora vamos con
el inciso b la composición genética de
las células hijas producidas por mitosis
difiere de la composición genética de
las células hijas producidas por meiosis
describe dos características del proceso
de división celular que conducen a estas
diferencias
bueno tal vez la más obvia la mayor
diferencia entre ellas es que la mitosis
consiste
en una división y la meiosis consiste
en dos divisiones esto genera
dos células hijas
de la mitosis
y cuatro células hijas
de la meiosis
esa es una diferencia muy importante
entre los dos procesos otra gran
diferencia y está relacionada con esta
de vida
a que la meiosis
tiene
una división
adicional
pero el adn
solo se replica una vez
al igual
que en la mitosis las células hijas
de la meiosis
tienen un número aplaude
de cromosomas
y podríamos poner aquí qué
las células hijas
de la mitosis
tienen un número diploide
de cromosomas
y estos son probablemente las dos
diferencias más importantes pero podrías
hablar de otras cosas podrías hablar del
entrecruzamiento cromosómico que ocurre
en la meiosis pero no en la mitosis
podrías hablar de la separación y
distribución independiente de los
cromosomas homólogos o de los pares
homólogos que se tienen la meiosis y que
no se tiene en la mitosis hay un montón
de cosas de las que podrías hablar y
entrar en detalle es agradable que solo
nos pidan que escribamos dos en cada uno
de los incisos de la pregunta 4